how's it going guys i wanted to answer a
question today here on code tech
tutorials that i've gotten on a few
comments on my blender video editing
tutorials
and that is simply should you be using
blender
for video editing the short answer is no
you probably shouldn't be using blender
for video editing just because something
can do something doesn't mean you should
use it it's
the main reason is it's just not made
for it it's not a video editor
blender is a 3d model making program
it just happens to have a video editor
with it because
you can timeline things and you can
sequence them
and then you can render that out into a
video it just supports all that
so you know the standard timeline stuff
that's that's the whole reason it has a
video editor so this has a location
starts here if i keyframe it where it is
and then go over here and say hey
at this keyframe i want it to be like
over here uh
save that then like you can you can
video play it back
essentially so that's the whole reason
it seems to have a video editor is just
because
it supports these animations and stuff
and that's like
a video type thing so when we go to new
video editing
yeah we get this whole sequencer it's
the same it's essentially the same
sequencer uses for the 3d stuff
there's a few problems i've ran into
that have actually made me stop using
this as a video editor and i'm going to
talk about those and show you
those just for full awareness i'm on the
latest version i have as of today it's
october 25th
2020 for sake of reference i have two
main
issues and i'm gonna also come to some
resolutions
so let me just i'm gonna open a recent
one i'm gonna re open a video that i was
messing around with
that actually gave me some real issues
okay so it has some issues with sound
it just bugs out with sound generally
sounds okay like if you just got one
sound file or two sound files
but where it starts having an issue and
this as far as i can tell
started happening in this latest version
2.9 i don't remember having this issue
in 2.8 of blender so if you have a sound
like for example so i'm going to click
here in the sequencer and hit play and
you can see what it's like
a goblin bushwhacker
kicker you heard the little kaching
sound right so i copied and pasted over
here saying kaching sound
for another one i'll just play super
goblin
seems to work okay so what happens so
say i take this
and i copy ctrl c and paste i want to
put it like i don't know maybe right
here
and just just play it back
so i'll hit play here and just just
watch actually maybe i'll just go over
here
there shouldn't be any audio of this
kaching playing right here but just
just listen
yeah all you got to do is copy and paste
an audio file and
that happens i did report this issue to
blender
so they know about it if you like try to
ever copy and paste
music or whatever to make it play a
second time
this crazy nuttiness happens of it
playing a million times that really loud
volume
so this has been a real issue with
editing videos because
you know you have sound effects you want
to reuse the sound effect
well you can't really because this
happens
now i will say that when you render it i
don't know what you don't know what's
gonna happen
like it might be fine it might do all
kinds of weird stuff with these copied
sounds
you just don't know so that's that's a
major issue
for video editors you you no longer have
control over the sound
you don't know what's going to happen
with sound so that that kind of that
kind of stinks
but the other issue and that's if you're
editing like a big video i'm going to
open this big one here
that i was editing it's super slow i've
proxied out this whole timeline to the
smallest proxies possible
on a you know proxy and cash can't see
because my face is in the way i'll
bring this over all right so yeah i've
proxied this
all out it's all i'm saying i did the
whole go to proxy and cache
click a clip do the rebuild you know
that the standard thing
set at 25 set the view to proxy size
doesn't seem to matter because it still
does this i don't know let's just let's
go to an area of the clip let's just go
right here
because i've proxied it down so small
it's really low risk but if i click over
here
you'll be here a while a long while
now just a minute imagine you're editing
like a video that's like i don't say
around an hour long
and any time you click you have to wait
five to ten minutes
we're like going back to the 1960s 1970s
of computer
era right here with with this video
editor at this point so that's a major
problem this is actually the major one
the sound one i was able to kind of work
around it wasn't too bad
but this one right here is such a major
time sync
when you're editing bigger videos that
just just don't you can literally
go install a different editor get it set
up and learn it before you could finish
one of these videos
so it just gets really ridiculous
and i can hear my hard drive like going
nuts i have a large spinning disc hard
drive for these large video files
which yeah sure it's a little slow but
it's doing some amount of excessive work
they've got some
some faulty or lackluster programming
we'll
say um behind this audio or the this
stuff so there's some
there's some issues they need to fix
before
this is usable again and if it is usable
i'll probably make another video and
update you guys
well what's the good about it why would
you use blender and why do i say it
depends
as the long answer well blender can do
about everything you can do fades
unique edits masking transforms
speed controls special effects
just about anything you set your mind to
you can do with blender
so that's a good thing and it's
installable on just about anything you
can install it on
anything for free but the sound and the
slowness issues are
too real for me so what's the solution i
don't know
like this has been locked up this whole
time i've been talking this has just
been straight locked up
just just by going to a different area
in the video just by like clicking
somewhere
it just it's going it's like it's
reading and writing
a 400 gig file just to switch to a
different
area i don't know what it's actually
doing but it's the hard drive is making
lots of noise so
i don't know why you need to do that
it's just it's just one little area it's
like
one png especially since it's all
proxied so
why on earth do you need to do this much
work to display one frame
i don't know someone really messed up
there though they it's like oh that's
just
oh you need to switch to a frame that
has uh
has random access so you can just go
right to it but no let's iterate through
the whole thing
from front to back and double check
triple track
quadratrek check it just go through it
again i don't know just
just run through that giant loop of uh 5
000 items no
10 000 items like 40 times before we get
to the frame and display it
i don't know it's proxied as a png just
go to that frame
and show that how about how about you
just do that that's that's
literally all it has to do is just go to
that png
and put it on the screen done i don't
need anything else what the heck are you
doing
all right i could go on i've lost hours
and hours and hours of my life
dealing with this as you can see i'm a
little frustrated no more
i'm done i'm no longer i'm no longer
using blender as a video editor you know
when it comes out with a new
major version i'll give it a try i'll
open it up and i'll try it out and if
it's good
i'll let you guys know um all right so
let's talk about a better option
resolve davinci resolve is the best free
one i've found
the one downside to davinci resolve is
it seems like you have to have a good
graphics card for this to run i tried to
run this on one of my laptops that has
like just a
default intel graphics card and it just
straight up wouldn't run
it like had some error resolve seems to
be pretty good you can do just about
everything with the free version of
resolve there are some options that are
locked out and
are paywall but they don't seem to be
anything super critical
so davinci resolve is pretty good that's
what i would recommend instead is just
davinci
resolve it's pretty easy to install you
just go download
download it from their website you'll
find it's not too hard to find
it's not too hard to install and it just
launches and works fine so
yeah use that i would say there's other
options there's caden live there's shot
cut there's open
shot those don't seem quite as good as
davinci resolve just not as robust and i
will do
a basic tutorial for you guys pretty
soon on resolve
on just like how to get started i'm no
expert with it i just started using it
but i'm good enough to like do all the
basic cuts do fades do transitions and
render out a video video properly and
make sure it's like you know good but i
think that's all you need when you get
started you just want to start with the
basics you want to start with something
that's like digestible and i think i
could do that so maybe and i'm having a
video or two i'll do that this video is
sponsored by
me that's right i am uh
i'm producing this video and i'm taking
my time to do it it's all me there's no
one else
trying to give a shout out to my patreon
and say hey you can
you can become sort of a sponsor i'm
going to be putting up some posts where
you can
vote on what i do next little as one
dollar a month you can literally
determine what i do next because you'll
be one of the first
and yeah once i do those posts and it
starts getting votes that's what i'm
going to focus on that's what i'm going
to start doing videos on
because right now it's just random as
you kind of might have noticed that's
that's the problem with being a creator
without a director is uh
you just kind of go wherever you feel
like you know with some direction
hone in on certain areas that people are
actually interested in
and i will pay close attention to how
people react to these posts that are on
my patreon so
link below please help out it would it
would mean a lot to me
ah yeah be it uh you want me to focus on
c
plus libraries or library managers or
3d stuff or video editors or whatever it
may be
c plus plus python c sharp unity unreal
engine
you name it i'm pretty good at all of
them i at least know the basics of all
of those and i could dive in and get
pretty good at any of them i don't know
i'm just one of those guys that loves
computers and has been doing it his
whole life
so and now that i've uh you know went to
school for it and
stuff i've learned even more of the
intricate details yeah this is pretty
much an ad for me at this point since
i'm the sponsor of this video
to the email on my channel if you want
your own
whatever me shouting out and selling you
instead
if you're still watching i appreciate
you alright peace out guys
see you in the next video
[Music]
you